hey guys how's it going i'm justine uh
so this is a little crazy but you're
actually seeing my desk and not a white
wall today now it's because i've been
traveling and i haven't really had time
to clean up my little white wall area so
this is what you're gonna get now
speaking of traveling that's what this
video is gonna be about now i travel a
lot it's really hard because i've been
trying to post monday wednesday fridays
here on my main channel so far so good
but when i'm traveling i don't really
have all the time in the world with that
being said
traveling definitely does give me
inspiration for videos like this one now
this past week on the plane i just sat
there and observed people now in my
observations i realize that most people
are idiots myself included i'm not
claiming to not be an idiot but let's
just be real we're all just idiots
especially when we're thrown outside of
our comfort zone like all of these
people random strangers being herded
into a plane with their luggage and
people have other things on their minds
naturally this will turn any normal sane
person into
like i said a complete idiot let me give
you guys some tips so that if you're
traveling you won't be one of the
traveling idiots i still am sometimes a
traveling idiot but with these tips it
will help you become less of a traveling
idiot first things first before you even
think about getting on a plane before
you even leave your house take a shower
just take a freaking shower for the sake
of yourself and for the sake of
everybody else on the plane that has to
smell your smelly butt don't want to
smell don't want to smell you nobody
else wants to smell you if you happen to
go out drinking the night before there's
a good chance that you're probably still
gonna smell like that bar brush your
teeth
seven times
bring some gum bring some mints you're
gonna stink now if you know you have a
flight tomorrow make sure you get online
check in find what seats you have now
that you checked in you know that your
flight is actually tomorrow be sure to
double check the date because there has
been times that i've showed up to the
airport and realized guess what
the flight that i'm about to board
doesn't actually board for another four
months mistakes were made try to avoid
that mistake next just know that you are
allowed one carry-on which can be a
suitcase small enough to fit in an
oversized bin usually they have little
things that you can just stick your
suitcase in and if it fits you can carry
it on if it doesn't fit you can't you
gotta check it one personal item this
could be a little bag this can be a
briefcase a purse something that you can
shove underneath of your seat now ladies
if you have a purse please take that
purse and put it underneath of the seat
in front of you now if you put it up on
top somebody's gonna take their ruler
bag shove it in there smash everything
in your purse break all of your makeup
break your phone break whatever this
goes for guys too if you have a small
bag don't put it in the oversized
luggage because it's probably going to
get destroyed by some idiot that's just
trying to put their bag up
now this leads me on to the most
important thing that i need you guys to
listen to when you're getting on the
plane and if you're struggling to put
your bag up step into your seat just
take a little step just take one step
two steps into your seat let those
people go behind you there's nothing
more annoying than standing behind a
person struggling to put their bag up
now if they're struggling guess what
person behind them you can be nice
enough give them a little lift give them
a little help maybe they're not strong
like you are i know i've dropped my bag
several times on the people behind me
because they weren't nice enough to give
me a hand we're all friends we all want
to kill this plane we all want to get
going i was going to say something else
but i had to choose my words wisely
another thing
guys
this happens it's a part of life but
look let me just give you a little tip
just
bear with me please if you feel like
there's a little bit of air gonna come
out of your butt just politely get up go
to the bathroom and let the air out
in the bathroom okay
please planes are very
very small and do you know what happens
with all the air in the plane it's
recycled
this is the motion of recycling
your poo air
poo butt
recycled so not only are you subjecting
everybody else to it you're subjecting
yourself to it
this is something that i always
appreciate so this happens to you i
encourage you to do the same most of the
time i fall asleep before the plane even
takes off and i miss the freaking snack
cart and there's nothing more upsetting
than waking up to seeing everybody else
snacking around you and what do you have
nothing no snacks for you so if the
person next to you happens to be napping
while the snack cart comes around please
just get them a snack just get them some
little peanuts get them some pretzels
place it nicely
right on there either on their lap i've
actually woken up and found
nuts on my lap and so i was like this is
great let's just i'm gonna just keep
that no i'm just gonna move on because
that sounds weird anyway i hope you guys
enjoyed some of my traveling tips i
actually was in miami this past week for
this conference called nat p and i was
on a panel with this girl named sonia
and she has a channel called sonya
travels it's pretty cool because she
actually gives real travel tips she
posts videos every thursday so depending
upon when you're watching this she may
have a new video out thanks for watching
guys make sure you subscribe so you'll
know when i post a new video and be sure
to leave me some comments on what video
you'd like to see me post next and some
traveling tips of your own because i
can't wait to read them
these were my traveling tips so i think
yours will be even more entertaining
i'll see you guys in my next video and
uh that's it do you guys hear this
freaking alarm probably not because i'm
gonna cover it up with music but stop it
stop it